in the last video I told you that we
would figure out the final velocity of
when when this thing land so let's do
that I did forgot to do it in the last
video so let's figure out the final
velocity chol and the horizontal
components of that final velocity and
then we can reconstruct the total final
velocity so the horizontal component is
easy because we already know that the
horizontal component of its velocity is
this value right over here which we this
is 30 cosine of 80 degrees and that's
not going to change at any point in time
so this is going to be this is going to
be the horizontal component of the
projectiles velocity when it lands but
what we need to do is figure out the
vertical component of its velocity well
one thing we did figure out in the last
video we figured out what the time in
the air is going to be and we know a way
of figuring out our final velocity from
an initial velocity given our time in
the air we know we know that a change in
velocity and we're only dealing at the
vertical now we're only dealing with the
vertical because the horizontal velocity
is not going to change we're going to
assume we've assumed that air resistance
is negligible so we're only dealing with
the vertical component right over here
we know that the change in velocity we
know that the change in velocity or we
could say the horizontal the vertical
component of the change in velocity is
equal to D is equal to the vertical
component of the acceleration the
vertical component of the acceleration
times time now we know what the change
in time is we know it is well I'll just
write down times our time and what is
what is our change in velocity well our
change in velocity is our final our
final vertical velocity minus our
initial vertical velocity and we know
what our initial vertical velocity is we
solved for it our initial vertical
velocity we figured out was 29.54 meters
per second that's 30 sine of 80 degrees
29.54 meters per second so this is going
to be minus 29.54 meters per second is
equal to our acceleration in the
vertical direction is negative because
it's
it's going to accelerating us downwards
negative 9.8 meters per second squared
and our time in the air is five point
six seven seconds times five point six
seven seconds and so we can solve for
the vertical component of our final
velocity so once again this is the
vertical component this isn't their
total one so the vertical component let
me well I wrote vertical up here so you
know this is the vertical component so
let's solve for this
so if you add 29.54 to both sides you
get the vertical component of your final
velocity final final well it's this
vertical component I didn't kind of mark
it up here properly is equal to twenty
nine point five four meters per second
plus nine point eight plus I should say
minus really meters per second minus 9.8
meters per second squared times five
point six seven times five point six
seven seconds the seconds cancel out
with one of these seconds so everything
is meters per second and so get the
calculator out again we have we have
twenty nine point five four minus nine
point eight times five point six seven
so we get we get our change our final
velocity is negative twenty six point
zero three elsei so this is negative
twenty six point zero three meters per
second and you might say wait wait cell
what is this negative twenty six point
oh three meters per second mean remember
and when we're dealing in the vertical
dimension positive means
up negative means down so it means that
we're going twenty six point zero three
meters per second downwards downwards
right when we land right when we land so
what is our total what is our total
velocity when we when we fall back to
that landing so are the the vertical
component of our velocity is negative
negative twenty nine point oh six times
oh three in the in the downward
direction and the horizontal component
of our velocity we know hadn't changed
the entire time that we figured it out
was thirty cosine of
degrees so that over here is 30 cosine
of 80 degrees I'll get the calculator
out to calculate it 30 cosine of 80
degrees which is equal to five point two
one so this is five point two one
meters-per-second five point two one
these are both in meters per second so
what is the total velocity well I can do
the head to tails so I can shift I can
shift this guy over so that it's its
tail is at the head of the blue vector
so it would look like that the length of
this the magnitude of our vertical
component is is twenty nine point zero
three and then we can just use the
Pythagorean theorem to figure out the
magnitude of the total velocity upon
impact so the length of that we could
just use the Pythagorean theorem so the
magnitude of our total velocity that's
this length right over here the
magnitude of our total velocity the
magnitude of our total velocity or our
total final velocity I guess we can say
is going to be equal to well that's let
me write it this way the magnitude of
our total velocity is going to be equal
to square root this is just straight
from the Pythagorean theorem of five
point two one squared plus twenty nine
point O three squared
twenty nine point zero three squared and
we get it as being we get it as being
the second let's see the square root of
five point two one five point two one
squared plus twenty nine point O three
squared gives us twenty nine point four
nine meters per second this is equal to
twenty nine point four nine meters per
second that is the magnitude of our
final velocity but we also need to
figure out its direction and so we need
to figure out this angle and now we're
talking about an angle below the
horizontal or if you wanted to view it
in kind of pure terms it would be a
negative angle we could say an angle
below the horizontal so what is this
angle right over here so if we view it
as a positive angle just in the
traditional trigonometric way we could
say that the what we could we could use
any of the trig functions we could even
use tangent let's use tangent we could
say that the tangent of
the angle tangent of the angle is equal
to the opposite over the adjacent is
equal to twenty nine point zero three
over five point two one or that theta is
equal to the inverse tangent or the
arctangent of 29.0 three over five point
two one and that gives us that gives us
we take the inverse tangent of twenty
nine point zero three divided by five
point two one and we get seventy nine
point eight degrees but it's going to be
seventy nine point eight degrees south
or I guess below the horizontal below
the horizontal or you could view this as
an angle of negative seventy nine point
eight degrees above the horizontal
either one of those either one of those
work but we have what's neat about this
is we figured out our final velocity
vector the entire vector we know what
that entire vector is it is twenty nine
it is twenty nine point four nine m/s at
at seventy nine point eight degrees
below the horizontal